in the mail very best lesson on and one
and we look at all the units we said you
could measure lengths which were
one-dimensional you can measure areas
which are two-dimensional and then you
can measure volumes right so how would
you finish the sentence the volume of
the solid is don't you define that -
somebody's never heard the word volume
before now capacity is a really
important idea however an I should say
now very very closely linked right
capacity is how much stuff you can fit
inside something okay volume is a little
- little bit different it's like the
difference between saying okay what are
the dimensions of this box versus how
much water kind of pouring up so we're
gonna look at capacity next week and
they are very crude but slightly
different everyone I have another guy
yeah yeah okay so capacities about how
much stuff is in something whereas the
volume of a side is the amount of space
it takes up and the important thing is
length 1 dimensional area 2 dimensional
but volume is three dimensional
okay which is why we have like
centimeters and meters for length we
have square centimeters and square
meters for area and then we have cubic
meters and cubic centimeters for home
okay now it's kind of cool because it's
not that complicated to work out if you
have a solid shape like this okay now
these are kinds of the main ones we're
going to focus on because you can see
it's kind of the same all the way along
right so if I were to slice this up into
pieces it would be trained a whole bunch
of triangles right so B then I can cut
it up all the way and get the same shape
over every game we call this heading we
call this
president actually comes from I think
it's Latin or Greek Latin I think comes
from the word fault that means cutting
or soaring right so it's like I think
I'll saw this shape into many many
pieces and get the same thing over and
over again right so a prism is a summon
where the way I would say it is a
consistent cross-section if you cut it
again and again and again you get the
same shape repeatedly right so sorry
with consistent cross can you draw this
shape for me I was a bit limited in
doing this I did really mean this to me
if a triangle rather than like this step
II being but if we draw one of these
things right and if you have if you
don't have a ruler or a straight edge
well let's draw one together
and to help you make it feel like a
prison right having these dotted lines
is helpful because we're using a 2d
space in other words my whiteboard in
your piece of paper we're using a 2d
space to represent a 3d object so
everything you can do like shading extra
lines you can't really see to help you
feel like yes this is a 3d object the
more you've got a boast about now if you
have another color there it will be
really useful because what I want to
highlight for you is this consistent
cross-section idea right so if I would
have cut this say in here so just eyes
up for a second and watch where I'm
placing us you can see the beginning is
a triangle and the end is a triangle and
everywhere in between like here for
instance all of those are also triangles
okay so we name prisms based on what
their cross-section is right so this is
well what would you call this our
triangular prism you can have a square
prism you can have a rectangular prism
so long as you've got straight edges
everywhere and you can cut it across and
get this consistent cross section it's a
prism okay now how do you go ahead
working out the volume of this thing
right all it means is how much space
does it take how much space is it take
so I want to take advantage of this
cross section idea okay if what I do is
cut this up many many times so that I've
got all of the different pieces right
you can see every time I break this
apart I'm going to get that same
triangle over and over again so just
need to know how many of those triangles
I've got so let's actually uh let's
actually use this will borrow the
measurements of this thing right you can
see what are they um if you treat one
cube as a unit right how tall inhale
wide or what are the base of my height
of my triangle it's three and three
right so let's just say three over here
or three over here okay you might like
to put some arrows here to indicate
what's going on so I can work out every
single one of these and I'm going to
break this apart a second every single
one of these triangles has the same
three by three dimension okay and
there's a for me
conveniently there's a right angle there
so we'll use that in a minute how many
of these triangles do I have what is the
the distance all the way across the
trailers it's 4 right so I'm gonna put
my form now this is a little bit weird
right we're gonna work out the area of
each one of these triangles and so we
call this a the cross-sectional area we
call it a now makes sense and calculate
it in a second
but this other distance right this for
what might we call it now depending on
the way you hold it you will call it
different things so for example if I
hold it like this so that the this for
length is facing from me to you right or
from you to me you'd probably call it
something like depth
maybe it's like how deep does it go in
okay however our convention is that we
try and think of the object upright like
this okay so we call this thing
just like in a triangle you don't have
to draw this but just like in a triangle
you see how this is not just the height
it's that perpendicular height so why
what is the height that's perpendicular
to my cross-section so I'm going to
think of it as very like this and call
this perpendicular height so since it's
fine I'll just use the letter H okay now
that's a bit weird because it's like you
know if I look at it like this it
doesn't seem normal to call that
distance which is horizontal to call
that height right um you wouldn't call
the width between my my shoulders right
you wouldn't call that my height but hi
it shapes like this it's kind of a more
malleable idea I can turn this shape
around and measure it in different ways
as opposed to me which you can't turn it
around we probably could because I'm not
heavy but anyway you get the idea then
this is what we got a call edge okay so
um can we work out what the area is in
fact could you use this as something to
help you what's the area of a triangle
it's 1/2 base times higher right now
just using these measurements base times
height is 9 and so half of base times
height is now let's just imagine if I
had to use this as my model right but
let's imagine that the units are in
centimeters okay so this length is
centimeters centimeters and Center
videos so what units are the
cross-sectional area movies across very
good square centimeters I've already
we've already described what a
perpendicular height here is okay so
therefore just need a tiny bit of space
the volume which again we're going to
abbreviate just the single better this
is a good choice the volume is going to
be the cross-sectional area times the
perpendicular
look you just get a whole bunch of these
just tell me how many of them there on
the answer is for them so I'm gonna say
a H four times four and a half hmm four
times four huh
I think that's 18 now remember I pointed
out to you what these units were in
right it's important you always have
been skipper measuring stuff centimeter
squared centimeters you put them
together centimeters cubed this is just
like your next Lord's as it is like if
you had two squared times two you'd have
two cute right you've got centimeters
squared times centimeters you're getting
centimeters cube it's not a coincidence